i watched a video
by what's his name glink is it his name
clink did a video about only fans yeah
and the more not not the sexual side but
more so the power of social side where
yeah a lot of guys are on there because
they that's like the closest they feel
that they can get to a girlfriend yeah
yeah and that was really sad watching
that video because you had interviews
with people who are only fan subscribers
you know and as much as we mean modernly
fans and and all that that whole uh
thing and uh you know earlier we
mentioned the whole dancing women on
tick-tock i do feel very sorry for these
guys like a lot of them that
feel that they have no other choice or
there is no other choice for them yeah
just to life circumstances or maybe
whatever's going on maybe they're too
busy you know it's uh you know and it it
is it isn't just the show typical guys
you think who are doing stuff like that
who consume that you know sometimes
these people just have no time they're
very successful yeah and they have too
much money but uh the one thing that uh
you don't have is time which is uh and
uh the ability to go make friends yeah
especially this day
yeah
it is hard like a lot of people are
lonely it's it's especially during the
times of the pandemic as well that's
like only kind of just
extrapolate
extrapolated that's only kind of
exaggerated
yeah exacerbated you know i feel sorry
you know uh for a lot of guys um
obviously as a as a male myself
it's one of those things where you can't
really openly talk about being lonely
it's quite difficult to do it you know
and um it's often hard to just reach out
to friends and be like hey man not gonna
lie uh i'm just lonely man you want to
hang out like it's yeah it's really hard
to do that and it's like it's that whole
stigma of like macho insecurity right so
i i always want to try and dispel that
and and be honest and uh try and be open
with my how my emotions and what i'm
feeling just so that hopefully that
other people can be more open with it as
well like i feel like when you're a
public figure it's kind of your
responsibility to
uh try and improve the uh
um understanding of uh topics like that
i think
you're allowed to feel emotions yeah
yeah yeah bro i know how so you know
because you know more often than not
there is a lot of um
toxic masculinity and pride that men
have you supposed to be successful and
provide and and uh you know basically
not be a fuck-up right
and those pressures are [ __ ]
difficult man yeah
i feel like a lot of guys end up pushing
up pushing a lot of friends away because
they're so focused on trying to not be a
failure um yeah and i feel like
especially with guys it's hard to talk
about it's hard to talk about something
negative like i remember yeah i remember
like i remember when we went back
uh to see all our mates and we uh we add
that to airbnb we're all caught up i
remember like going into like a
conversation like a deep conversation
that some of uh some of our guy mates
were having at that time i remember
sitting down
uh on the table and uh
like uh one of our mates was talking
about you know going through therapy for
one of one of the things that they went
through right and you know uh more more
and more people started sitting sitting
in and then started
sharing their stories about how they
also were go through something rough
especially during covert and they had to
like seek therapy about it and then
eventually we just had these this whole
table this group of guys and i was just
like wait a minute has anyone here not
been to therapy
we look around and nobody puts their
hands up and i was like so wait so
everyone here has been to therapy and i
was just like
how have we never talked about this
before we've known each other for like
four years it's a shame thing right yeah
a lot of guys feel
shame admitting that they they have any
of those problems yeah exactly and i'm
just like if something should be
normalized and not be ashamed of frowned
upon it's just it's this you know it's
admitting that you have a problem and
you're seeking help and it's it's like i
feel like especially especially in
england and especially in asian culture
it is very much frowned upon to like say
hey i went to therapy or i talked to
someone and i was just like because it
like the mentality is that if you go to
therapy then you are you're inherently
trying to fix something about yourself
you're in here there isn't something
inherently wrong about yourself but i
think people don't admit that there's
something wrong yeah i'm not going to
just avoid it yeah i think that's that's
that's that's absolutely [ __ ] you
know just speaking like
trying trying to keep like a healthy
like
a good mental health is not it's not
something that should be frowned upon
you know and i feel like america and
this are like leagues ahead of other
cultures and just accepting this
and
gender doesn't stop you from being sad
like if you're sad it doesn't matter
what you identify as if you're sad
you're sad and if you need to talk about
it you need to talk about it like yeah
because the the male suicide rate is so
high yeah man like
[ __ ] so
sad thinking about that well the male
depression rate is so high as well
there's like no one [ __ ] talks about
this thing right when i was in uh
in my first year of living in london
looking back i could easily tell you i
was depressed but at the time i didn't
know i didn't know why i was miserable i
didn't think i i i was like i have no
reason to be sad so i'm not sad that's
because he had no one to talk about yeah
yeah yeah bad mood but i also didn't
even
because i hadn't been educated on it no
one even told me that that was like
who tells you what depression feels like
yeah how do you learn that i didn't know
what it was yeah i didn't understand
what it was and only now when i look
back and i think oh i had like all the
[ __ ] the trademarks of depression
like i didn't want to hang out with
anyone but i also was lonely yeah
and and there's tons of other catch-22
right it's like it's it's and normally
it's being your own worst enemy um but i
didn't understand that and and i'm very
very lucky that i managed to just get
out of it on my own yeah and that now
i'm much better and i think it was a
whole slew of reasons of why i i don't
feel that way anymore uh mainly like
just life reasons changing yeah but i i
wish that i had had more education on it
in school like in wales it was never
[ __ ] brought up depression was for
people who were crazy that was not what
healthy people have with normal jobs and
wives you know you can't be sad if you
have a job and a wife yeah yeah exactly
you've got a 50-inch plasma screen tv
you can't be depressed
it's harder to take seriously because of
the environment that you're in oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah well i was just miserable
in school anyways like i
yeah it's it's it's really difficult and
it's really uncomfortable thing to think
about yeah and there are times in my
life where i'm like oh yeah i'm near
certain that i was like miserable and
and very very unhealthily so very
self-destructive but i just didn't
recognize it i didn't know why yes the
main reason is like
why yeah no no one not most of the time
nothing makes you depressed yeah it
happens yeah and i feel like you know
it's going back to what you're taught in
school it's just like oh the you know
seeking help therapy those are for the
crazy people yeah exactly you know it's
just like you
you know what you don't want to be
associated with the crazies with someone
something you know and it's just like
that's just not how real life is at all
a lot of people have a lot of issues and
like some on varying skills but there's
nothing wrong with just [ __ ] talking
to someone professional about it there's
nothing wrong with seeking help yeah
like you know
when it when you're when you've had it
for an extended period of time um i
didn't know i was like well this is just
normal this is how i've always felt i
don't know i don't know anything else
this is
what do you mean that's when it starts
to get scary yeah yeah because that's
all i like for a while that was like how
i just felt all the time so i was like
oh no was nothing to complain about this
is how it's always yeah because because
your memory is very good at letting you
forget things yeah over a year so you
very much forget how it was yeah um
you'll be you could be you'd be
surprised how
easy it is for your mind to just accept
things
you can get used to a lot of things and
it's it's [ __ ] scary how you can just
get used to like a lot of
like a toxic period in your life or like
a really bad period in your life and
your mind just like accepts that as norm
and if you forget that life could be
better that's you that not everyone
should feel this way yeah and
unfortunately our mind has a terrible
way of coping with situations we don't
like yeah and uh our brain is [ __ ]
amazing at like
hiding [ __ ] from us so yeah so for a
long time i didn't know why i was sad
but i i couldn't figure it out yeah the
brain is very good at just like [ __ ]
putting on the emergency handbrake
sometimes and being like don't think
this it's really good at like
that that little little brain is really
good at distracting you little [ __ ] that
boy yeah oh yeah
yeah i i implore you to
think about it more and uh if you are
don't be ashamed to get help don't be
[ __ ] ashamed of it dude don't don't
be and don't be ashamed to talk to it
about your to to talk with your close
mates about it because that's the
biggest thing i think i'm very very
blessed that i have good friends yeah
and if your mates don't take it
seriously then you know that's something
that's telling off your mates that's
probably not your mates that's that's
telling yeah that is telling because
because i've you know i i realized then
that i was lucky enough to have mates
you know including you guys who i can
talk to anything about you know and it's
not just here it's back home as well and
i'm just like damn i got a pretty good
group of friends i feel pretty blessed
right now you know i'm obviously not
going to bring it up every goddamn
conversation no no no no you can you can
bring it up
it was a [ __ ] bro moment when i'm
just like i'm glad we're [ __ ] talking
about this now man yeah but you know i
want all my friends to feel like they
they can they can come to me yeah yeah
and trust and be like listen man i'm
really struggling yeah yeah let's let's
let's do so let's sit down let's talk
about whatever you need man let's figure
it out like let's let's do it like i
want you to be happy mates don't want to
see mates being sad oh man
you know the one thing that i've learned
as i'm getting older god forbid i'm 25
and i'm saying that [ __ ] but it is it is
it is
i notice it is harder to make friends
it gets it gets more difficult to make
good friends yeah because everyone's
doing [ __ ] yeah
you know and i feel at that point as
well everyone already has their like
established group of friends have their
own friend groups and stuff and you know
and it's
i remember when i was growing up
everyone's just like time is your most
valuable resource and i'm just like what
does that mean
[ __ ] off give give give [ __ ] off give me
opening give me a million dollars and
we'll see how isn't going to buy me a
mcdonald's meal okay shut up dad logan
is opening my pokemon
[Laughter]
yeah it really started to hit me when uh
i just wanted to hang out with sydney
and now she's like got her own career
and everything we literally had to like
schedule a date that we've never had to
do before and i'm just like what we have
to book out time to spend time with each
other you have to pencil in a date i
have to pencil in time to spend time
with my significant other and i'm just
like good time management what is this
what is this
yeah it is very weird yeah and um it's
like time management is a thing that you
have to learn as you're growing older as
well and
like also you just don't have as much
energy as you did before like it's like
your energy levels do like go down
because your patience for [ __ ] just
like just it
it dwindles you know i'm like i have
zero of that now yeah yeah just like
immediately i'm like i'm not gonna waste
time on this because now i know how
valuable my time is like i finally
understand that time is your most
precious value i know i finally
understood after all the [ __ ] i went
through like oh this is what this means
and it's not even like oh i could use be
using this time to make money no you're
not i i mean i could be using this time
to be happy i can't be using this time
to hang out with my homies to play some
games yeah like like anything but this
[ __ ] like if there's something that
makes me angry nowadays it's something
that wastes my [ __ ] time i'm
literally like literally like i don't
have many pet peeves but if i feel if i
do something and i feel like i could
have been i could have used that hour
doing something else yeah i i i that's
the biggest thing that makes me angry
man i could have been like i could be
playing like a good [ __ ] game could
have like been hanging out with my
homies yeah could have been could've
been doing anything yeah anything
anything to make me happier than where i
am now
japanese government are building
20 000 hours of
waiting oh my god